[Musique]
on
oui enfin l'eau et nous faisons nous
devons trouver une manière de façon pour
faire en sorte que notre histoire
arlette de mon site et limite ses
frontières moment là c'est que je suis
et c'est pour cette raison que nous
avons accepté et reconnu la martinique
et bientôt la balle ou prendre le relais
à son prince et même si vous demeurez
une région française et je recommanderai
les citations du milan ac ont causé des
français la balle mieux soin mutuel je
savais plus comme ce qu'elle allume ils
vont changer ça français
célèbre jour nationale de sète aussi aux
nationals qui a lieu normalement le 13
décembre
deuxièmement ont raconté les fonds pour
notre police maritime à cet outil qui
ont besoin de l'équipement et en
équipement qui est très urgent c'est une
wasla ça coûte 25 millions us et donc on
essaie de les aider et troisièmement on
voulait créer un environnement où on
peut avoir un échange les discussions au
plus haut niveau ça veut dire au niveau
de cultuelle financière économique
linguistique et hansson est donc cette
soirée est très important où nous au
consulat et je vois pour le moment que
c'est bien mais ici
g
là et comment je dois penser à ce que
nous faisons ensemble qu'on va continuer
elle reçoit ce qui empêche ses seules
qualités
[Musique]
nous avons trouvé un petit appartement
sis est visible au jeu il précisé bush
et que par conséquent il ya croissance
d'avant
[Musique]
doté d'un ensemble
[Applaudissements]